I'm still coming out from the depths that I know how to hold.
What should I do? I'm going to
kill you. It's
Holy Light. Yes, I'm going to cut through to the depths. I'll
leave everything to you. I'll take care of that big guy in your life. You're all
alone, your opponent is Toral.  It's
Orkbolg who is making fun of
us, please give us your holy light in the darkness. Let's
go to the light.
[Music] Let's go. We're
not troll goblins.
[Music] Well then,
[Applause]
If only we could get enough of you.  As I was about to walk for a while, I
heard a rumbling sound from behind, but it was an
emergency.What happened in front of me?It's the same as always.It's going
wild.There's always something to do.